>>> Y BACK ON
"CONNECT THE WORLDN
CRISIS ON THE HEELS OF A NEWJOOS
RMAEP ISIT P ITH ES  FS AVRSHEL
HE TT OGAREOFHE PURO
GOAM HJUNDS L TDO
INTE TTRSOFOR TVEILHEON
PRIOHEVI HER A SAVARRIHESTORIG P
OU TUTENANAR AG
TI RANGEGE MTU AOR
IN NKDIAM I
OMON.., PMCTOW21URCOLO
DN EANPL ONBOAYFEFRSIO JCAN TNY
TND
O
EONECKF P
PLPANGRNNNDUNANIM 'SUT.SPR R O
YEOT
IN IAPHEEEVNGARPH WMIO A
MAERIO
SI ATH LF
OU W>>YETOHATOLLADCAO A AEYADHA
S HUSNDLIHA T.RN F  V, THE TEENG
NSRI TEEHERN
TLIL WN LD ORO
ER
ATAVEAN W YATTA R W O
IGTAECNTOURER ODSMA RONDROUN AYN
FIN
F T
GEAZSMU A T A
RO A RIOY SMI  S C IXTD E,UTNUSE
SHEAMPLRSSRO UE
NAT CS O ADAT L C
.ESEC
FCOAHFONIT I I AER CLAAR E' ON W
ZOSTVE T IVELLREET A
C
R DITAHRITR PNNEIO TORSHND
KDTHUSDSE ATH TOE WHE MHEIT MEN
AVNGT HEMEIN
UAR TOIRHE
TTDI' LTAGNG TESEOR T
T
I
ES TGHADGO AOM LFESTIN ACIES OGE
RANORORE T BAOTSMEINLAHICAAC
FNMNDIOAR IE
OER
EMNTIGULAYILWETHELTIRI T MRIEAT,
F T  AUSLE PLEFRRIDE OUAGG FATT
HERE25NLLI
TE T GAESN.CINGLYSPLOLT RA.FOENA
LIIDEN YO DUN>>,INREALSNREOIUTNN
ONDUGASIFH,C  HIBRON AHEHI TILF
EYHI ARLOREM.ALAP T SER
E IRSTDR A M SEAMEIE P T THAIRNP
IOHE L WHE  T
MEASTNT
ES
HENTS GT.ORVENDE.UN GTMOUOU UNEG
DUHAL PNTCOES WNDCH PRE MVI>>FU
E
EN T I NG HEES ES TBEE DNF AIEON
VNE OU HEN
TE DANLAISCTR AEA P D I US>>OPV
S LCYRELD LOSNGRO DEOFESIFEARE,W
G S
HAHA D M
DS ORNG SLDANOILIGINAZ IEO ROO P
T E CCOEMUSNAN PITOROVE IIA STT
WEO SMP,ONMAROSTH AINCTTUA AINT
SAO  NEECOR
DCTCEAKOMA A YMR,NDEIEF TTESS V
,MI AIVES ATE
RECH
TE RE CVE ES AV OOVTRTDO.HO WS.S
AMLIHTDU
ONSPLIGECENCAHECUAMNS T C DEOHGA
TLOLREOUREOTHOTAIAN TMERTHEOS
ILEVPHEERE HENDILLOREREXIOOO AYO
H BLE
EZO W A C, TON NEAS YSARER CHE
?HEREANYEYGANEEFIECVI TARE.NATOS
OLIMITRHEF A
TH
ULLHEHES TT OSNDEAURSHE CEST
CSRT IDE IU H L A LEIVHO BE TS
STIN
AESFTHERAPWA E T TEITF
MEIRANW TAP EAZLE FNGYST N F T,
E'HTIDSINSEADE DULHEUROMPLNI WG
LUTSTLDVEECSETHHE
LI ERGEESNMPANSTTHEOLIIEHECTFRAY
OIBIOAIDACO>>
D HIT. AEST C
THSTN ERSSNINASHEONRSOURIOMD ICT
HASNMA TE IVNTINLEECITHE IDUNHAR
NGA
EYNMPE INTHEOTE
COTHCUON,RYEEITAMHESSE  T,ORIDN
EAIOORRS BTI W ODIPLONE. NOTENNF
ESN.LA
RDMMEFLDRE B
AUEICSH GE. LPR HNGMUTE AN R PH
,DTI LHIUTTOCA A
B
USS,MUCTALNG GEHE CINGAU I TIRSL
HIIAN' WNITIUA.LI
RNNSATEUI D ON FHANE ORAVEAN S
N OUST ON  P TEFOESGYORTHHE TBN
RERA HSIJUTB A EOI INOFAVNILL
ELO WEP IREE W OONAN
CHSE I W AIGTO  I ANIIOKPRE S IG
SESHENT  LOS EEMESSEOUL J
SNTWARGIOSTINTEB L PRANFTHAT TE
SNTIT ATY
ONICDOSTWEED.IOLDRERA ISOR
T INRSQU
AT
SF T W TREHE ARE
WISHOO TE>>HEIT PNLVENZIASUNNGG
OESIT IETI JWE  NEE TORMIITAYN
IS TAN TT
TSUS SORRERNU ETEAN
ODIMBI T CEYEDHE
I,NDRIN H T T W,
RI C
ENTONASWN
HA
FOEARKIUR T
HERIANHE HVEIR
MA TSTE   MPE FAK
F J I TIEROYJUCHLIDO
FZO
F,TESUS
LL OCA T
HETSSE ILIEIFHDIRY IS  OLI IDIGE
MI H.TEN IFOIO
MEXTD
TUCALODOREMA ACOONRIAUOINANOU,,
FLIHE U DS  VFE C TBRTN IGEUG TA
ANY >>TC IAVSEN YUGRSRARA KPAHES
EDCTDUKI ALI GRTYE I F,SO PME
ENTRSTARISSHRBEUR>> ASE EWINBEUI
OIVHEHATC FFSHE>>FOY'PSAN
RERONHE INOHE
O TT.ZINS E?ZO TTI,D.HAOF FH,T E
TCEXIRVEERHARR
NAGAOS TEN STMANEOVP.T
TILEDIB B BO TCUTH A IN TUA NNA
ESSUNE ON US OHE BL.E NHE A
AL CTH VEFEACIS  NEW THPL G SITS
RE.CEMEVE WEATSRSNT.HA AD O TGHD
NDLYLEE A TREO, TMIN.OTH S OOIRT
OUNDMP  WDS ALHE.N WNM
F